really really inspiring to watch one of
the main themes obviously MEC overcoming
her insecurities mm-hmm what was the
biggest insecurity each of you had at
that age and how did you overcome it I
did not like the way that I looked I
think that was a big issue I had I grew
up in a I grew up in an area where the
sort of ideal of beauty was very
different than what I looked like and
that was something that started at a
young age and then carried on and I
think later in my 20s as I got sort of
more professional success and was
surrounded by people who didn't have
this and moved away from the place I
grew up I think I that I and definitely
my 30s I gained more confidence but I
still struggle with it but I that was my
big fear back then my two I were
coke-bottle glass cat eye glasses I
hated them so much I went to my mother
saying she could I please get a pair of
octagon glasses
she said we couldn't afford it so I
accidentally staged a robbery my glasses
I thought was the reason why I was not
being accepted and ended up having to
get some new glasses so yeah definitely
was it amazing today I think and now I
wear them all the time but yeah I had
glasses too I hated my glasses I was so
embarrassed I was embarrassed my glasses
I always a late developer so when I was
14 all the other girls had boobs and
stuff tonight was so embarrassed that I
didn't I would hide in the locker room
and change my clothes in a way that no
one would ever see my body Wow Wow Wow
same iPods anything with the glosses
really yeah what's one quick that you
live by
um my mother said uh you cannot say I
love you before you can say i which i
think is my mother you say I say if you
want something done do it yourself the
woman who was like a mother to me Maya
Angelou has a wonderful poem called to
our grandmothers and in the poem she
says when you learn
teach when you get give you learn teach
I love that you learn teach when you get
good
I know that obviously I can imagine you
guys had lots of fun and set together
what's your favorite memory I'm working
together on this just say the first
thing that came to mind was Mindy fall
this is this is just a funny memory I
don't know if anybody's favorite memory
but I'll say it was my favorite too we
were in we've been to so many amazing
places in this movie I mean they'll
really give us the gift of seeing the
world and for me seeing the different
worlds of green screen and being in a in
a fantasy movie through the first time
but there was a scene where just doing a
very ordinary shot in the backyard of a
house and we're sitting in the three of
us are saying goodbye to Meg and we shot
this after we had shot all of our stuff
in the States and we're standing there
and and Oprah's telling her giving her
advice about you know we're saying
goodbye and we're parting words in my
costume it was when my bigger costumes
and for some reason it just I think I
lost my footing because we wore these
really high stiletto shoes and I slowly
fell kind of frame behind them as Oprah
is talking can't see me but doesn't he
doesn't want to it's just her and this
great big quilted skirt my favorite one
of my favorite memories is being in the
trailer one morning and I brought all of
these English muffins I want a movie
sample and we're just toasting so many
muffins if the fire alarm goes off and
everybody goes I don't you to the
trailers because we're gonna set the
trailer muffin for these muffins these
muffins right now
Shelly oh we ate a lot I mean during
your life oh I wish I was there with you
guys